hi i'm imani hakim and i'm ashley burch
and on mythic quest we play
game testers let's say you liliana the
red ready to beat some ass
but today we are giving some other games
a test
today we will find a champion get ready
for some high quality
quality control paddle ball testing for
bounciness
and self-defense something bad is gonna
happen
get back out of here jerk
[Music]
this is what makes it all worth it i say
it's pretty fun
yeah i'm bad at it but i still enjoyed
myself just trying is half the
best that's all you need can you do
tricks
come on doggy mine is so disobedient
this is like isn't there around the
world yeah you're doing it
it's happening juggling
three points fun rating 2.5 i agree with
that i feel like it's got a good
girth uh what i don't think the balls
are the problem it's
the problem oh don't be so modest you
guys got the goods
cup stacking testing for stackability
they stack
well okay okay i get it
[Music]
wait there's one more i think they're a
little small too small
you want more i was gonna say girls
again for the second time punch balloon
this one's pretty good this one's pretty
girthy is there a proper way to do this
it was weird huh before are you a good
paper footballer
yes
apparently not
breathe
[Music]
oh that was awesome man i think these
games all kind of have some bugs
yeah they suck they're not games they
were fun but not as fun as with the
quest raisins banquet which you can
watch right now it's streaming only on
apple tv
get ready for season two
you